les chéris battle de scoop chacun à un
scoop sur la télé vous allez nous dire
celui que vous préférez et je vous jure
que ce soit il ya trois coupes assez
forts dont une fois vous avez travaillé
on va démarrer le scoop
bah oui ils vous ont donné une petite
chienne n'hésitez pas une pression sur
l'échangé sanchez on va essayer vous
voilà vous avez des doutes sur mes
toiles à l'étoile a permis l'échangé
non mais c'est pas ça parce que vraiment
il a des idées ils y dorment et ses pas
il est dans une crevasse changé de mains
ça me gêne quand même si c'est bien mais
tellement publiée trop mais ça tout
s'est fait ça n'est jamais arrivé à
petit on sait à quoi ça fait de la peine
mais non
vous avez les trois coupes qui veut
démarrer
damien canivet ce vous avez un scoop
parce que d'abord c'est le scoop que la
france attendait cyril je pense que
c'est le meilleur scoop détroit vous
arrêtez la télévision
il concerne une animatrice phare de
france 2 veut daphné bürki va présenter
la 33e cérémonie des victoires de la
musique en février ou mars prochain sur
france 2 ah oui c est déjà ce que vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne idée oui est
ce que le scoop vous intéresse alors à
gâteaux pour vous êtes dans l'émission
vous êtes dans ping pong à merci alors à
dakar et géraldine oui c'est plutôt une
bonne idée mal à trouver un peu bobo un
peu chine massa service public
alors moi je vous dis la vérité j'aime
bien daphné mais généralement quand on
vous fait présenter les victoires de la
musique c'est vous allez quitter la
chaîne une énorme talent on fait jouer
c'est moi j'en ai fait je suis parti
deux mois après l'annulation
c'est le cadeau des partages unis
normalement oui c'est une très mauvaise
idée calmez vous elle rate totalement sa
saison arrêté le catastrophe c'est une
émission qui va atteindre son pire
niveau d'audience
j'en prends les paris et les sens je
trouve que c'est de la merde
elle fera tout seul alors normalement
elle sera tout seul et je trouve que
c'est une excellente idée ça mais
c'était une bonne idée ou pas merci
normalement il sera tout seul enfant
selon mes informations elle sera seule
alors voilà c'est un scoop de l'année
tout en la musique ou regarder ou pas
ouais ouais mais moi je trouve que c'est
une super ici mais j'aime bien moi je
trouve ça va être un peu richir
marocaine
c'est hyper malin de la part de france
télévision je sais non mes voyages
ça ne fait pas mention europe alors
qu'elle marchera sur france 2 moi je
suis d'accord qu'elle l'a un peu mou
bobo à vous le disiez qu'il allait pas
autant dans l'empathie une fois s'il
vient leur ton est déjà dans autre chose
elle est pas née celle en soit encore
possible pour les émissions de
témoignages tout ça je pense que daphné
sur scène et où c'est plus son style
d'animation réseau poursuit michel 12e
et bien cet anime approche a beaucoup et
la notion de bien aller à l'aide était
rien et légitime
grafite beaucoup dans le monde de la
musique donc c'est vrai qu'à la liste
des cérémonies et autres drogues n'est
pas une insulte pour moi c'est cool baba
qui n'insulte jamais castany vous à
madrid
flavie flament
après l'énorme succès de son téléfilm
son mariage et l'avenir c'est pas à ces
gens n'est pas du temps encore les
barrages soit avant qu'une aide aux
couches torrent les balles c'est sûr que
ça va te faire ça te faire du bien moi
je te donne mon tableau fesci merci je
fais une journée de merde qu'il fait là
vous parlez en est une autre
ici on est dans touche pas aux boîtiers
deschamps ps eh oui alors actuellement
donc à solferino nous attendons
l'arrivée et non de ségolène royal bien
entendu un merci alors votre scoop on y
arrive donc elle devrait faire son
retour sur m6 en janvier avec une
émission sociétal développé avec klm
filiale de manager six d'accord alors
donc place du flamand pour un retour en
janvier à la télé sur une synthèse sur
une émission sociétal mais sociétal ça
veut dire qu'il ya pas mal de dents way
attendant toutes les émissions yamada
je crois que vous avez la phobie des
pièces de deux euros à chaque coup
j'avais pas sûr
chez les messieurs sociétale excuse moi
mais c'est la chaux très bon scoop mois
sa main avec la vue flamand qui revient
là t'es pas de nouvelle bonne nouvelle
bon il n'a pas encore tout le concept
mais c'est prometteur il avait déboursé
obama aujourd'hui c'est une bonne info
et parfois c'est le genre dans lequel
elle excelle donc on a hâte de la
retrouver dans une émission michel par
mois aux nouvelles
c'est sympa de louvain moi je suis
d'accord avec tout le monde là les
gentils michel st amour dit charlotte
damien absolument voilà ça serait une
mission l'après midi benjamin césar mais
il sait pas l'après-midi des camps du
créneau à ce que je suis pas sûr que les
dents mexique l'habitat mans oak et
revient à vis d'une bonne nouvelle c'est
ça sur une émission après sociétal sur
m6 c'est pas trop le public je trouve
que c'est plus déjà alors gène j on s'en
fout du concept qui sait pas trop ce que
c'est est-ce que flavie flament c'est
une bonne nouvelle ou comme une
excellente nouvelle elle fait partie des
rares animatrice qui ont beaucoup manqué
ces dernières années je serai très bon
mois les deux poumons le plus manqué sur
la tête de ma mère un clément il a juste
parlé sérieusement c'est flavie flament
et pepita de pyramide mais les cadeaux
étaient en fait un choc qui ces deux
pépites à cet égard mais les garçons et
ronchon et marque la bulle suis pas
convaincu j'ai pas convaincu par son
retour sur m6 n'avait pas les retours si
jamais à les aimer le départ ne pourrait
être plus service public
je la vois plus sur le service public
que sur m6 je crois qu'elle a failli
revenir sur sa vie finalement ça c'est
pas fini non mais c'est vrai et bon mois
moi j'aime bien un planning aussi non
monsieur richard
oui c'est bon ça va bien on a un enfant
on sent quand même fait patte à la
compagnie non on partage le tabloïd et
de partager un enfant oui très bien on
embrasse enzo qui aime beaucoup
d'ailleurs il en garde on savait que je
l'adoré non mais c'est vrai mais aussi
les miens ça tombe bien bas c'est normal
messier bien sûr on aura le scoop de c3
et après bien sûr il y en a qui sont
placés pour un autre scoop gagne son
duel françois fera ce qu'on croit
mais si là il fait chavirer les coeurs
rdc compte dubosc et services de franck
dubosc et de phil barney direct franck
barlet pas forcément je suis marié marié
bravo tu as de la chance tu as dit aussi
a été mariée on mais on met pas pas
mettre le jingle du valdonnez direct
moscou moscou du jour concerne une
personne autour de la table cette
personne va écrire un livre
mais un livre un peu particulier c'était
pas géraldine maillet mais c'est
monsieur jean michel maire qui va écrire
un livre sur le sexe à n'en point douter
qu'ils n'étaient pas un livre sur l'or
mais l'anthropologie 1
au départ le livre était intitulé le
grand livre de la tob c'est une vraie
information 69 conseils pour séduire
ça sort en mai c'est un livre drôle avec
beaucoup d'autodérision des images
également je sais pas trop quoi y voir à
mon avis
donc je cite bar le grand spécialiste
français de la tob écrit gros forcément
je vous ai dit ça sortirait pas votre
arrivée vous cherche à quelle heure
alors est ce que c'est vrai staff ont
dit oui c'est vrai mais c'est plus bonne
à non c'est vrai ou pas c'est après fra
bat bien sûr cette année devrait sortir
libre en mai sur le legs de saisie sont
sur la table at home
la fiom à la plage la tob à la montagne
ça jusqu à clignoter aux toilettes ou
sur la plage chez hugo et compagnie jack
lang fabia de lettres votre ami voilà on
se voit un peu tous les après midi on
travaille un peu soit sommes tous les
deux bien pris très dur et c'est
franchement vous avez des beaux projets
vous avez des beaux projets de vie sains
domaske apostrophe n'existe plus je vais
faire les illustrations
c'est lui non ça sera une photo
essentiellement ils échangent des photos
libres de droit et vent est censé nombre
d'accords a très bien d'enthousiasmant
de travaux on connaît on connaissait
jean michel comment c'est toi qui on est
on est les plus grandes maisons
d'édition sanctions c'est un très beau
projet et vous êtes la bonne personne au
bon endroit dans le franchement c'est
vrai bras vous bonbons à ce que pour moi
mais c'est bon merci vous qui a eu le
meilleur scoop ramassant décrire
méritant la musique des victoires de la
musique bref né mois jean-michel
benjamin benjamin pareil dans jama -
maxime j'aime les livres
tu rigoles seul tu rigoles isabelle g
ricains entre benjamin et damien mais
benjamin oui le niveau est faible mais
benjamin le scoop de maxime gagné sera
celui qu'on va retenir d'accord
jean-michel maxime aussi maxime et vous
il n'y a pas quelqu'un qui pourrait
démentir le scoop du livre
fouquet michel c'est matt zaba max pons
alors il va écouter ses maximes guény ya
eu le meilleur foot est bas et bien c
max est gainé de très peu dans la
caennaise merci d'avoir participé